だーっに見えるヒコーキホ人が何に見える自家用ジェット機今月は初めてとですいう
わけでここ静岡のお茶なんですけども僕の家の特徴といえば玄関が独特なんですねここ
玄関なんですけどもご覧くださいここらへんはで自分のフィギュアが飾ってあるんです
けどもこっちがもう
壁が全部レゴで出来てるんですよねこれで外から入ってきたとき
のパック未だ瞬間でもをレンズによく来る人だった入った瞬間一さんちっていうか
わかるわけですねこれもうこれがあるだけで春3冊お部屋だってわかると思うんです
けども
もうそんな常識をくつがえそうというわけで俺の部屋によく来る人が競ってあげた瞬間
他の人の家だったら特急やっていきたいとおもいます
なーに簡単ですよねぞうで行
部屋がダメなんですこの現代のせいで肇社長の部屋だって思うから玄関の構造を完全に
変えますあけな瞬間猫がなくなって無事の玄関になってたらその前で誰ちょっとこれ
始めたんですかなってなると思うんですよ
誰とずでも皆考えるわけですよ玄関の模様替えしたのかなって思うわけですけども
そうじゃないそうじゃない根本的に
違う家だと思いたいここ日本なんですけども35とかなんだ4つとか別の編入っちゃっ
たのかなって思わせたいので便がを完璧に出てましたの霧のようにしてこの家に家族を
置いておきますがちゃんだけど瞬間肇社長じゃなくて娘とお母さんが出てくるようにし
ますもうそれでこのように入っている人は思うでしょ
家の書類に入っちゃったそう思う
あふれたようなボールの質最高の勝ちパターンはがチャットで開けてあっいくつ違う
玄関でず出てきた人が外れ地蔵崎てから知らない家族が出てくるあってで間違いました
と言って締めて
あれって部屋番号まで確認したらフォルム勝ちです知らない人の部屋に代わっている
ドッキリ
すぐやっていこうと思いますでいこ
入ってゆくでまずはどう見ても普通の課税の喧嘩じゃないんでまず
の家庭の玄関に治していきます取れずレフを買っておきましょう
[音楽]
ええええ
カートへうわーーー
生後と良いや破壊するタイプ
[音楽]
うわあああっ
だーっふわぁ ua
me
ん
うん
よし片付きましたこのテーマ市の方を何もない状態なんでここからいろんな模様がい
たら知ってまで家族が住んでいるかのような玄関にしていきたいと思いますでは早速
妙な玄関作っていきましょう
持っていた
お母さんお父さん娘
いい家族のゲンガー
どうぞ完璧に早急の直れないですねユーチューバーのいいじゃありませんいやーこれは
さすがにオレンジとは思わんでしょもうええええインテリアコーディネーター売りを
受けて完全に一般的な家庭にありそうの原価を彩ってねたわけないが肝心な家族がい
ない肝心な家族実はお母さんと娘さん準備したんですけども
a
明日きます
おやすみなさい車
[音楽]
お願いシャワーをすると途端にいうね
というわけでん
娘とお母さんを用意しましたよろしくお願いしまーす
でシャワー
としては俺の家だと思って皆多分ピンポンも授かった入ってくる
陰陽2人が入って突然性は何か入ってきた感じを出していただけるといいですね
me
千葉市ました
ちょっと声でやってみましょうか
[音楽]
ていまーす
どんどん増えて煽ってんじょ
んか
ません
プレっスコ
いや一さん静間5加工
えっ
あれっ
釣れました
くまままなんでまあまあでせ
メンバーはねぇ
家に入って何してるんですかありがとうござい
から始めるんじゃないんです
はいこれじゃあそれっぽくがええよねまぁ間違い桂てください
[音楽]
そういうわけで仕組み完璧です完全に家族の喧嘩
家族
おっと新しい国でいませんすべてがとうございました
早速ターゲットでいきたいとおもいます
ん
さあする目のターゲットです最初のターゲットは等摂取ちょっと足事が話だ
失礼だ始め者園生やったんやくると思うんですけどもさあ話でいいしていく
さあここで務所が出てこない話だから早過ぎるとばべスピードがない出てこれない娘が
詐欺にいい子やなぁに入って来
お礼先にお母様と接触しましたさあ
どてるえっ
まあその顔になりますよねさあ様ですか
さあここで男モデル性が出てきた天才子役現れるさ
親子にからバレるさん達のは怖いよねさだよです
こういったねもういいですよね
さあここでしっかりと後日を確認する肇社長の部屋だと間違いないと見てその後彼は
ラインで引っ越したって聞いてましたありがとうございました
2人目のターゲット2人目のターゲットはトマトくんですしっかりどんどん二曲が入っ
ていきます
サービス目当初
はいします挨拶から入る
かそうなるよね
逆に誰
確かにもう完全に肇社長のお部屋だと思い込んでいますね
さあマーリーを確認する間違いない
そこでお母さん退治
あんた調査んですかあ
清水と申しますもうまずは名字から入る一さんの家ではない
あっ違いますけどお二人に越してきた
前から住んでますけどあこれで前から住んでる低下してしまうあっはい間違えました
はいはいさーすぎな感じになりながら部屋をアウト
謎を抱えながら部屋に戻ってきますタッチだってこれはどういうことなんもう別世界に
有用なのか悪かんぺぱぱられるわー
ん
さあ3人目のターゲットです傭兵先生ですねもちろん迷いなくお部屋に突入
おはようございます
うわぁ
ラベルの等補助びっくりしますよねそれは4話
んあー
笑っちゃいますねこれは
ねあされましたよねうんせいでまたしっかり自己紹介からですね
ua
ああああああ
う知らない人来たねえんどなたですかあったよ
両陛下の時だけなかったが強いあすいませんはいここ
武器なんですけど柄が気に入ってこないいます後8日
アースが怒られた感じになっては確認しましたカフェにはしっかりと確認からですね
多田肇社長の大口だと思うんですけどああいえコンってます
はい違いますねそういたしましたそういうのを誤って出ていきますお部屋をアウトする
も腰の低さが魅力的ですありがとうございました
さあ4人目のターゲットです圭佑一番俺のもう市仁連木しているタイプ
フェスとはなんでしょぼいクリスマスん散歩ですね大事
夢じゃありませんま大先生活動でした
すぐ出ると思ったんで私しっかりガードしておりますさあこの中でありがとうござい
ana dj dj なんだろ政府ですか
ブービーパキッに会にお招きされてるッ
そうです
どうぞこちらさあ疑問同社真上上がっていくぜ
こうして三人は仲良く暮らしますたとさ
あっは
[音楽]
blr